Well
hello, how are you, greets Héctor Mejía
with his informative brief, today is Thursday
, April 15, we have good news
regarding the country's economy, the
employment department released its
weekly report, in which it appears that
576,000 Americans filled out the
unemployment application  last week this is an
estimated 200,000 - just a
week apart and the lowest number
recorded since the start of the
pandemic at the state level the picture
is not the same since more than 11,000
applied for unemployment which implies
a slight increase  compared to
last week the after house restaurant
will offer a job fair today
it is looking to hire waiter partners
and many more positions this event will be from
10 am to 2 pm at the same
restaurant located in perdáis and carmen
remember to bring your resume
meanwhile there are still many places
around the valley that offer the
pzifer and modern vaccines
and the convention center are  the two
largest but there are smaller sites such
as the genetic centers are
so for more information visit our
yingxiu dotcom page diagonal in
Spanish
and now we turn to the weather we will see a
clear and sunny sky due to some
clouds passing through during the day there
will also be winds  in the northwest of the valley
reaching 25 miles per hour for
this afternoon then nice weather for
the rest of the week hovering around 70
degrees have a nice journal I'm hector
mejía and this was your brief informative about
them in spanish
[Music]